this has been an ongoing debate yes when
you see a man first undress yeah what
are you hoping to see boxers briefs or
TIY
whes
boxes oh my God wait Angela loose boxers
why are they loose okay box breef like
the ones that are tight no you yeah
they're not
loose yes so that does not mean what you
think it means she said loose she was
shocked shock was even an
option you guys we have merch and it's
live right now and it's so cute I can't
breathe Christmas Christmas and Hanukkah
Christmas Christmas we have a holiday
merch drop and there's a baby pink
hoodie that is so cute I cannot wait to
get my hands on it at the same time you
guys get it and you can find all of our
cute new holiday merch launch at itsr
tuesday.com and honestly we all like we
never usually agree on things we're all
obsessed with this launch we're so
excited it's so squeed when I saw that
pink hoodie like it's never leaving my
body also like guys we give you
permission to go to an ugly sweater
contest or party in our sweatshirt our
Christmas sweatshirt because we are sexy
little ugly girls so it counts we have a
holiday sweatshirt a crew neck
sweatshirt and then we have the cutest
little like is it kind of like Asian is
that okay to say I'm Asian yeah everyone
gets a pass that makes me so happy it's
a little ravy like if you wore it with
like one of those ball necklaces and
jenos it would look really cute oh
that's a good and a studded belt space
buns with space buns you got your Asian
part in okay you guys go to it's trash
tuesday.com for our merch drop that is
officially live today these will sell
out we can't wait to see your selfies in
them and repost you tag us we love you
yay you guys this Thursday I'm going to
be at the Irvine impr C doing standup I
can't wait and then New York I'm coming
back I'm doing two small shows in New
York the week before Thanksgiving
November 18th and November 22nd and then
I'll be in Los Angeles finally I'm
adding an LA show December 6th at the
comedy store and then my rescheduled San
Jose January 7th all of those esteron
i.com you guys sluggy I am so excited I
am coming back to San Jose this weekend
I'm bringing Lizzy cooperman with me
it's going to be absolutely wild so
that's this Friday and Saturday then I'm
going to be in Houston Texas at The
Improv December 15th through 17th I'm
going to be in Canada and Edmonton
January 12th to 1 13th and Jacksonville
Florida at the comedy zone January 19th
and 20th I am constantly adding shows so
go to Annie letter.com shows to check
those out and uh Annie wood and friends
is once a month at The Comedy Store so
look for those dates as well and I will
see you every Thursday on annwood love
you guys thank you to our sponsor
meundies to get 25% off your your first
order plus free shipping go to
meundies.com Tuesday that's meundies.com
Tuesday for 25% off plus free shipping
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
find your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com sltr
Tuesday today to get 10% off your first
month that's better help
hp.com Tuesday thank you to our sponsor
prize piics go to prize.com Tuesday and
use code trash Tuesday for a first
deposit match up to $100 prize picks
daily fantasy sports Made Easy you guys
take advantage of living proof's biggest
sale of the year now go to livingproof
tocom Tuesday and use the code trash
Tuesday 25 at checkout to get in on
these deals before it's too late
livingproof
tocom Tuesday code trash Tuesday
25 KLA for your birthday I got you
Angela
White thank you so mucher for your
birthday I got you titties so Brown well
here we did since Angela is our guest
today Annie did try to Contour my AC
cups and now I just look like you have a
skin infection yes something that I'm
peeling somewhere on my chest so thank
you Annie for the birthday gift you know
who probably knows the least about titty
contouring is Angela White because she's
doesn't need that no I've never
contoured my titties you're just you're
just this way yeah Welcome to our show
thank you for inviting me I like when I
first walked into the studio and I saw
her I was like who is this beautiful
angel like she's so pretty I just I'm a
little bit I think I'm going to be like
how Bobby was on tiger belly where I'm
just going to be like hey nervous to
talk to you like I've never seen Bobby
that way had you ever seen him that way
no yeah him and Gilbert were just like
beside themselves they could not like I
it was strange the energy was so like
you know Bobby's like big energy it was
even bigger there was some type of like
I I I it felt like he was like juggling
the whole time like and also trying to
talk to you but focusing on juggling
like
juggling
yeah um is he like is he are they like
like longtime fans is yeah but didn't
Bobby say like he's like once once I
know you I can no longer be a fan or
something like that yeah but he did take
it back when I said well you know I feel
like that's unfair because I would still
support him and see and like watch his
standup shows so he should still support
me he should support your craft that's
funny is it fair to say he was brown
Star
Struck what he was brown Star Struck cuz
he's seen her her butt no I think in
that episode she saw his
oh we have seen a lot of his things
interesting colors down there in Bobby
world aren't there I I thought his
butthole was very nice like it really is
though yeah it it's incredible
surprisingly tight he's kind of like
surprising a lot of things about him you
think you think he's going to be messier
than because he presents outwardly messy
no no no he's messy no I know like
physically messy but you'd think his
body would be no he has no body odor
like he does his armpits never stink
it's unfair it's I just love that he has
this lifelong policy where he's like if
I met you I can't watch your stuff
anymore and then all you had to do is be
like that's not fair and he's like okay
never mind yeah it's like over he defers
to the hotness what's our theme today um
I think it's sleepover slumber party
pajama party how do you sleep Angela how
do you sleep at night what do you wear
um it really depends on the weather and
my mood but I I'm partial to some PJs
really cute little yeah I don't like to
sleep totally nude cuz they go
everywhere I need to have them contained
in like a crop top or something I know
that it doesn't seem like it but I do
relate to that like I really do identify
as a woman with extremely large breasts
even though they're like humble
bees um and I don't want to ruffle any
feathers but I do believe that large
breasts are a of a disability they're so
uncomfortable I
agree you're like oh I'm getting a taex
right off hanging out with
your but do you isn't it like I could
never go shirtless sleeping cuz you like
it would just be
so messy do they okay so when you guys
like lay down they just kind of like
separate and does it hurt does it pull
it doesn't hurt but it I mean they do
separate they do they do all sorts of
things I've got they live their own life
and they're out I just like to have the
support of something whether it's a bra
or like a crop top or something just
keeping them in line they need to be
controlled oh I like that keeping them
in line they need to be disciplined oh
it's getting hter like they're in
different
moods wait I don't have symmetrical
breasts either mine are symmetrical and
small mine are tiny but when I lay flat
they still somehow separate to the side
and that's not a look that I love I mine
are already wide set I have like wi you
don't you don't I have wide set we both
maybe it's the shoulders and the tits go
together we both have like we're the
shoulders of the the tits follow the
line of the shoulder but I think you
kind of remember my friend Caitlyn from
middle school like she had like really
big boobs but they actually like
technically weren't that big she was
short she was small so like your boobs
on my body would look like probably kind
of like your boobs yeah are your boobs
really a be I don't like a BC way when
you no way but they're not like huge I
mean look I prayed for boobs this is not
exactly what I wanted but I landed
somewhere okay you know you just wanted
someone else's boobs on your face you're
just SC I also prayed I prayed for boobs
you did yeah I did yeah I was I felt
like I developed late compared to my
friends like I was really flatchested
until suddenly it felt like overnight I
had double D's and yeah I used to cry at
night to my mom like that I didn't have
boobs and then did your mom have big
boobs yes my mom has big boobs my sister
my
cousin my mom's mom has big boobs my
dad's mom has big boobs and here I was
with nothing you're like the run of the
family yeah I was like come on please
when you did finally get them was it
like a big celebration like oh my God or
were you like oh [__] what do I do with
these it was a bit of both I was so
excited to finally have boobs and the
power that they brought but then they
grew so quickly that they also came with
these really large purple stretch marks
which I was embarrassed about so it was
like oh now I have these big boobs so I
know I can get what I want but also but
also but what I want is these lines to
Goa do you feel sorry do you feel like
you're someone that would ever consider
cuz a lot of my girlfriends who are like
you know actually have big boobs not
like me that pretends would you consider
a breast reduction like is it like that
for you or no they're part of my
identity okay yeah I I don't know who
would be without my boobs your boobs are
part of her identity too that weird yeah
I always patted my BR like I my mom had
a a a tumor in her pituitary gland when
she was growing up so she like didn't
develop normally so she had small boobs
but I thought it was Associated to that
and so I just assumed I would be like
the che your like I'm the titties in
this family because she was adopted like
I was like I'm going to start the tits
in this family and then um I would pad
them with socks as I did today Annie
would Annie Annie [__] Letterman
socks you can get them on my website but
um these exact pairs from the titties
yes since I was a child yes you can have
these ones no but I I would pad with
socks and stuff and I would look in the
mirror and I would spend so much time
like what am I going to look like this
and then I never like this is a water
bra I just never got them they still
have water bras but that's a part of my
identity never getting them oh so I
understand they my expectations were
managed very early on cuz I had a you
either have a a n mom or not a n Mom
right you either have parents that walk
around naked or parents that are just
always fully dressed around you you
don't seem like you had a n Mom I just I
hate the term n Mom I had a NY mom and
if I had a n mom there's only one way to
describe it and it's a NY Mom right it's
like the bush you saw the bush every day
you saw the titties every day you saw
them look at themselves in the mirror n
and I looked at my mom's body and mind
you she's like like a bodybuilder right
but so I knew very early on that I was
never going to have Bo boobs so when I
when they never grew it wasn't a
disappointment it was like oh I am her
daughter this is a weird thing my mom
has no boobs but me and my sister both
do and we have different dads so it's
like we both got big boobs like despite
my mom having no big boob in her lineage
what no big boobs in your mom big boobs
like in Angela's family like it seemed
like everyone had big boobs I don't
really think of my grandma that way I
don't know I don't look at her that way
you never like I feel like grandmas are
all about the boobs like snuggling into
their boobs and hugging their boobs my
first grade Aid Kia had like the best
boobs in the world would you just hug
her and you'd bounce and I hate to say
this Esther but at some point like we
have to see our parents like genitals
like alfresca because when we take care
of them when they're older like I had to
I had to confront my father's penis and
change his diaper at some point why you
remind me of this I heard I saw you suck
in
air I saw a reaction no one is ready and
I hate to say this like this is such I
hate that I have to even say this out
loud but there is a thought in your head
that crosses where you're like oh papa
is hung oh my God Kila that that didn't
cross my mind when I my mind when I saw
my dad I went oh papa is not hung or
he's hung no no no no I just said I
don't I remember it being bigger it's
like when you go into your Auditorium
that you went in your Elementary School
I was like oh I guess I got
bigger dis
adjusted how do you guys sleep how does
do you sleep with how we just spoke
about our parents genitals how do you
sleep at night I have to sleep with
panties on
because I have to like my [__] where's
my [__] juwes going to go just crust up
on my inner thigh I understand that I'm
so sorry I know Stella's mom is here I'm
she loves it I'm so sorry speaking of
parents genitals anything you want to
show
us I cannot sleep in underwear free the
juice I I feel like you have have to
sleep with it on your face or something
weird why dad do you sleep I sleep uh
naked if possible as naked as possible
like if there's people in the room that
are not my loved ones or not well my
parents I don't sleep naked in front of
but I will still like hoist up my
mother-in-law and I Todd's mom and I
will like FaceTime with just like wow
our sheets on she's always topless I'm
always like we're always just topless to
each other you know why you know why
she's a NY mom she's a n mom and she's
also going through menopause oh she's
Hot and Hot and Hot and It's like show
us the tits don't hide them does Todd
sleep naked with you no he sleeps with
underwear on but I yeah no I have to no
everything's it's not hot I have to have
D tape on my mouth so I don't mouth
breathe and like a nose thing on it's
not a good-looking thing Angela I know
on tiger belly we you said you didn't
know what dating meant yeah but what is
it like being a porn girl and being
interested in a boy like how does that
work out like what are the rules that
you strike with them what's been your
history of
dating it's
usually someone's interested in me like
I'm so focused on work all the time that
someone has to kind of like knock down
my door and be like hey I'm interested
in you for me
toing already no it's opposite for us
right for like stand up you like no one
is knocking on our do but if they are
it's like uh how did you get my address
sir the cops are going to be here second
no they're like how did you start open
mics like what's it like they're like
asking for advice do you have guys do
that to you where they like hit you up
and they want to do porn yeah and it's
usually at conventions I'll do
conventions to meet fans and so many of
the fans like I want to get into porn
how do I get into porn just like awkward
because it is really difficult for men
to get into porn it's much easier for
women yeah Julian's like sign me up I so
interesting that we're talking about
male porn what is it I it's easier to
get into gay porn than it is straight
porn yeah but then isn't it harder to go
back into straight porn once you've gone
into gay porn like you have to like it
used to be but that stigma has really
changed yeah it's it's not as big of a
deal anymore your makeup's so good I
know staring at your mouth move I'm like
oh my God I'm like is this a date like
I'm so in love look at this mouth wait
do you go on dates I don't
know I feel the same way I feel the same
way you don't know what dating means
like what
some people after that episode have kind
of explained it to me a little bit more
so I guess I didn't really understand
the difference between going on a date
and dating right like at what point like
how many dates until you're dating and
is dating serious or is dating casual is
it something when you say you're dating
someone is it like does that insinuate
that there's a future there or is that
just oh no we're just those are fair
questions like who does know that CU
yeah dating can actually mean like or
boyfriend girlfriend or were just dating
yeah and I like when guys tell me that
right before I'm about to meet their
entire friends from college guy do that
were just dating yeah right right when
he was like you're meeting all my
friends by the way we're just dating
like wait so I didn't know that either
because I um I was dating a guy and in
front of my family I was like oh like
we've been dating and he was so offended
by that he was like no we're not like
I'm meeting your F same thing but I
didn't understand it either I was like
wait what what were do you remember
hooking up used to mean like just making
out hooking up is just hooking up sex
was like what do you mean hooking up is
just hooking up hooking up is just
casual sex occasionally like a Friends
with Benefits remember when it
transitioned from like I remember in
Middle School hooking up was like you it
was just making out I remember watching
lagona Beach and me and all my friends
at school were like what does hooking up
mean is it sex or not CU they always sex
but there's also seeing each other like
where does that fit oh we're seeing each
other seeing each other I think is a
good boundary yeah kind of like serious
seeing each other but if you're seeing
each other are you boyfriend and
girlfriend or no not
yet you're like starter like it's on its
way maybe like in Filipino courtship
there's five very clear steps and this
is why there's no confusion in Filipino
dating and over here everyone's confused
what are the five steps the five steps
is before you even before courtship you
have to ask permission to court so let's
say for instance I'm interested in
Angela okay I can't immediately just say
I like you I have to say I'm am I
allowed to say I like you oh that's good
am I about to humiliate you or not am I
going to humiliate you or are you going
to humiliate me right now yeah so
there's that first step it's asking
permission can I Court you and if you
say yes then the courtship happens then
I do this thing called a harana where I
serenade you but it in wait you're
courting okay I'm courting I it's either
outside of your window and I'm either if
I can't play an instrument I'll play a
song I'm
out this is good there's a spider video
I watch this weekend that I need to show
you guys we have to pull up spiders like
courting each other how they it's crazy
and there how men should be like they do
dancing I love that they're like birds
of paradise it's like what are this type
of spider I both don't want to serenade
nor be serated but then there is just
want to show up and and then just fall
each other's genitals but this is why
there's no confusion because after the
courtship progresses then if if not the
serenade you have to put some type of
like soft launch statement either like
if it's social media like something to
insinuate oh like you're seeing somebody
and then you enter the stage of mutual
understanding you're not exclusive yet
but we're not sleeping with other people
three is the soft
launch it can be inter it's
interchangeable because before social
media what was a soft lunch like showing
your taking them to see your family yeah
so the the harana is it's basically a
public showing that I am interested in
this girl and people are watching me
sing to this girl that's a commitment
it's like yeah and they should be
dancing this isn't the I'm trying to
find the oh that is it wait they like
wave and then they shoot this thing up
like and after you enter Mutual
understanding mu you then you are
official okay but there's a between
Mutual understanding we're not sleeping
with other people to finally official
there's there's space there so stop
sleeping with each with other people
before you become boyfriend and
girlfriend and how do you become how do
you come to the mutual understanding you
say are we yes we are usually
understanding yes spider so I love a
step system that makes things so much
less but also just you know what it does
it shows commitment on the it's going
like I'm I really want to like pursue
you and make sure you're really
interested in and people are going to
know I'm pursuing you they kill the guy
so fast if they don't like him like and
they poison him like though female
spiders yeah that's female insects in
general they always mutilate or or kill
the male after I mean it's like we're
really not taking advantage of our
nature really that's probably the male
they're always better looking cooler
looking they're so pretty I know it's so
awesome all those eyes too well speaking
about um genders in
insects you did gender studies correct
not not in insects not in insect but in
humans yes um yeah I mean I did a
Bachelor of Arts I majored in gender
studies I did my first class honors on
my thesis on female experiences in the
Australian pornography industry right Co
was this before you were in the industry
I was already in the industry yeah but
before I moved here to La oh wow yeah
okay so like there's a lot of famous
people in LA right but you're like such
a specific
intimate and also very famous person
what is your experience like in daily
life like can you go places or do you
get anxiety like do you get recognized a
lot do people even say anything are they
too nervous like what is the I mean I
don't think I'm that I'm famous to a I
guess a lot of people know me but um
it's a really interesting type of Fame
because some people feel embarrassed to
come up to me in public
or um yeah it's I I can definitely go
out and do things I do and I do get
approached in public but a lot of the
time it's more like the kind of the
knowing stare or like the the Double
Take I'm sure there's a lot of waiters
that are like spilling drinks when they
come over to
you their boners are just knocking the
but when I'm in La it's kind of easy
because everybody knows somebody in porn
so it's kind of it's a bit more
normalized and do you live here now I do
yeah yeah I moved here in 2016 awesome
and before that you were in Melbourne I
was in Melbourne yes and what's it like
be being famous over
there um you know my fame really Rose
when I moved to LA um so now when I go
back I'm more recognized than when I was
actually living in Australia um and it's
it's similar I mean Australian culture
and American culture it's not the same
but it is similar we we heavily
influenced by American culture so it's
the same kind of vibe you know there'll
be like people that will feel maybe a
little intimidated or embarrassed to
come to me that's why I do a lot of
these conventions because some fans are
actually really shy too and so being at
a place where they know I'm here
specifically for to meet you so then
they feel like it's an appropriate time
to approach me it's like an even
exchange too like they like they paid to
come to see it it's like a yeah it's not
like awkward or yeah okay I did a
standup tour in Australia years ago and
I had two takeaways and I want to know
what you think okay a Australia had
weirdly like the best coffee I've ever
had and the best Thai food I've ever had
so that did you like you know that I
know that yes is there anything else
that I'm missing or were those the
headlines really good Sichuan like
Chinese food because it's such a Melting
Pot like Melbourne was is probably my
favorite place to eat yeah cuz I dated a
guy from there I mean he wants to kill
me
but right yeah he no longer wants to
kill me but at one point he did didn't
you like call and wake him up in the
middle of the night once on the show and
wasn't he like hey babe like he was
ready for I don't think he wants to kill
you anymore I think he I think that was
pretty that was rude of me like how did
my ass taste that was the question we
asked him in the middle of the night if
someone is going to Australia would you
say like you got to do this Cuisine or
anything you'd advise food in Sydney I
think the Thai food in Sydney is better
than Melbourne but then Italian Greek
food in Melbourne it's all about like
the immigration patterns um there's more
Asian immigration towards Sydney and
then after World War II there there was
a lot of um European immigration to
Melbourne so that's why the coffee in
Melbourne is so good I agree like food
in Melbourne to me is the best best in
the world freshes food I've ever had was
in melbour too yeah we have great
Lebanese food like I was even in Perth
like who the hell's been to Perth but
the food it's so good everywhere fres
the produce is so good that must be yeah
I feel like for me the Thai food in
Sydney is better than the Thai food in
Thailand I believe that I've been to
Thailand and I think the food is great
but I feel like the produ is even
fresher in Sydney I don't know and you
guys say bre my headline of
Australia is Corey The Party Guy Do you
remember him there was this kid will you
Google Corey The Party Guy in AUST it
was so burned into my brain like I he
like takes precent of all of my which is
insane I know but I just think about him
like I'm always like Australian's party
but I don't know if that's true it's
just cuz I'm thinking of this kid he got
in trouble he he had threw like a huge
party and it got busted a house party
and got busted and he wouldn't take his
sunglasses off in the interview and I
think they were like are you gonna do
this again and he was like yeah there
was a game
today this is I'm so sorry but this is
my entire feeling about Australia Wait
no that's like I see that and I'm like
is that your has that been your goals
this whole time yes that's why were
that's why you Tred to make me take my
sunglasses off cuz we want to see your
pretty eyes you're very predatory today
she's a groomer she's grooming me for
something a good
podcast this has been an ongoing debate
yes when you see a man first undress
yeah what are you hoping to see boxers
briefs or tidy
whes
boxes oh my God wait Angela loose boxers
why are they loose okay boxer breef like
the ones that are tight no you yeah they
not
loose yes
that does not mean what you think it
means she said loose she was shocked she
was shocked it was even an option no you
guys are selling something different
boxers are not loose boxers are the
plaid shorts pull up some examples and
by the way no not the Plaid ones
watching
this thank you Angela make sure you show
her that was a how the Mighty Fall you
were so excited it wouldn't disqualify
show me what you think that likes yeah
okay so these are what I like or this is
what Esther likes show her just regular
boxers this is these are
boxers so that's what Esther likes okay
I mean are you my grandfather are you my
like maybe you could sleep in those
exctly this is what and I yeah yeah yeah
what do we call those box of brief box
of briefs okay yeah see how excited she
got about box of yeah box of brace you
guys are disgust those are skims panties
to me that's so weird and you don't your
favorite thing they're your favorite
thing to you not on a guy I wouldn't
disqualify someone wearing
like whatever briefs or looser boxes but
I would prefer boxer brief yeah yeah
they just as long as they're clean yeah
yeah but why do you guys like that
there's something I feel like with
boxers there's more like sweat accumul I
don't know why it just seems to feels
little like for me at least I cannot
imagine wearing something loose
underneath my clothing cuz things would
Bunch up and I equ bunching up to like
just discomfort and sweat and things
getting shoved in the wrong places
look Julian obviously put that up Julian
you put your own picture up there that's
what I hope to see Angela what do you
think of tight Whitey ties tidy whitties
tidy
whes um that's a diaper that's that what
what you've just pulled up is not sure I
mean if they're they're clean but it's
yeah I mean I clearly like black
so okay preference my hipster guy
friends went through like a colored tidy
Whitey phase where they'd have like blue
on it was cute I didn't [__] them but it
was cute to
see okay so let's see what
the Instagram poll showed okay okay what
so the Instagram poll revealed that 72%
of our listeners prefer boxer briefs 24%
which is much higher than I thought
agree with you eser boxers and 4% tidy
whes wait I have a question for those
are gay slugs you okay wait Esther you
had used to have a podcast called weird
adults like you identify as being a
little weird right yeah but I didn't
think this was weird do you feel 24%
weird or 4% weird or 72%
weird or I guess it would be the
opposites do you feel 20% normal this
felt I just this felt so you're
blindsided yeah yeah as we are when a
guy is wearing regular bases why do you
like them to me that's like masculine
and like manly to me I don't know the
other one is is feminine to me wow yeah
I know that that's like you can't make
those judgments they're kind of 90 I can
for my own taste yeah I think so I think
for me I I equated to either being
childlike or fatherly
I only see like really young boys or
like my stepdad like Roger wears like my
Dad wears tidy blackies he said he
stopped wearing tidy whes years ago well
that's what Angela lies yeah yeah oh my
dad so hot cute 82
82 I just feel like we're on we've been
doing this show for several years now
like Kila obviously has way worse and
weirder takes than me so I feel like how
is this the weirdest I mean it was also
the confidence in which you I think that
is a lot of it it's the fact that you're
so you're almost like cocky about it
you're like obviously everyone agrees
with this yes what are some major turn
offs um that you have in men and women
yeah bad hygiene oh hygiene yes
arrogance like the standard like the bar
is very low when they go together too
isn't that really bad yeah they like
your breath stinks why are you being
rude to me pretty cocky for someone who
I'm flossed in three years
that is such a horrific combo when
someone is rude and they stink it's a
little Spectrum you're like are you on
the [__]
SP I think name dropping too oh I'm into
that tell me everything tell me everyone
you know now I hate it I don't like that
it's so it just screams insecurity and
it's such a turn off Annie your take on
name dropping I love it give me all of
them tell me everything I will name drop
other people's name drops like if
someone name drops them I go oh my God
yay I have a noob you know it's bad when
she's name dropping me at an Asian
restaurant oh my God it was awesome I
was waiting too I was like we all do
that did it work they worked so I knew
it was going to work I knew it was going
to work I was like he's going to know
who I am in like 10 n 8 7 and he got
it we need to do a poll that is I lost
my train of thought what were we just
talking about name do you poll if people
like name dropping or not like name
dropping and let's let's let Annie have
a little taste of being wrong I don't I
like being wrong I surrender to to that
to be honest Esther I you're very unique
I don't know yeah unique is good my mom
think that's a good thing oh thank
you I like the uniqueness I don't like
the boxers this reminds me of a song
from the musical Chorus Line where the
girl says different is nice but it sure
isn't
pretty no that's sad what is broke out
the song and started dancing I I I
may um second so arrogance name dropping
bad
hygiene God those are great ones those
are good ones yeah um it's kind of the
standard yeah yeah yeah um what other
ones what are your major turnoff Esther
outside
ofers I mean everything Angela said is
is a turnoff you've dated people that
are very much that besides the hygiene
which thing arrogant and Nam
droppy you people that are the top of
those in the
world yeah when they were Starbucks
employees like how much did they name
drop they just name drop the people's
names that's like pretty much a
Starbucks
job
uh
um I don't what are your guys's turn
offs
you um I mean Under the Umbrella of
hygiene like breath is like my number
one number one I think
rudess oh you see that in guys cuz they
think that that's going to make them
like it's like the Arrogant thing where
that they're if they're a little rude
too then they think that you'll think
they're better than you but it's like no
I need Ultimate 100% kindness and
generosity coming at me or get away
no bad tippers people that are rude to
like waiter I mean that drives me crazy
that's sort of like the type of people
that wake up like I dated a guy who was
like one of those like woke up in the
morning and it was like his day and he
would just [__] on it was like no
acknowledgement that other people are
just like working and going about their
day yeah he was me to my mom what is
like a turn on like if you were meeting
a guy on a date or something and like
some like what are qualities that would
get you like yeah some green flags
exited green flags um kind of all the
opposite of those like being hygienic
being kind um I love funny
guys I don't know if that's a green flag
it could a red flag I believe it is a
red flag it is someone really funny what
if they're not Comics though they're
just like you know no that's true fny
yeah funny is good you just don't want
guys that have developed humor because
they didn't get late in high school and
are now using humor as a way to have
power over a large group of women in
cell Vibes well well said very well said
but there's some people that just are
funny because it's just like in their
genetics and how their family was I
think there's yeah I mean we've asked
this question on the show before like
how big of a value is someone like how
important is it that your partner is
funny and for the longest time I know
you said it was important you said it
was important I think for me we just
have to be able to laugh at the same
thing yeah like I don't necessarily need
him to be funny but he needs to
understand what makes me laugh yeah you
want the literal senses of humor to line
up to match yeah because I remember
dating a boy and he was a lovely man I
could have stayed with him forever but
he was like cry laughing on the couch
watching this video and I was like oh my
God like please show me it's got to be
the funniest thing on earth and it was
just a Bus full of baseball players
singing Karly Ray jebson song and there
was nothing funny about it and it was
just super cringe and I was just like
and and I was like why are you cry
laughing on you want can I can I think
of why it might be that you hate that so
much it's because now you're in an
awkward position where you want to like
you want to validate that he's laughing
but it's not funny to you so then you're
like I'm either going to be sitting here
like [__] on his parade or I have to
like fake laugh well no I went
immediately to the other to my friend
and I was like can you tell me if this
is funny to you cuz I need I wasn't sure
why I wasn't laughing I hate when
someone brings up and video you don't
realize how long like funny videos are
until someone doesn't think they're
funny next to you and you're just
holding and you're
like or someone does it to you and
you're like okay we got it because I
feel like I'm like insulting their taste
you know I'm like oh my God now I'm like
rejecting who they are as a person I
always say no like I have a I'm like no
I say no just say no you are good you
are good at because you know what I can
be on my phone looking at a screen all
day long at home when I'm out in public
with people I want to [__] talk I
want to look at you like I don't want to
look at your [__] phone screen I
don't care who you are yeah I ha that
you [__]
[__] anyways Angela you're somebody
that performs and you
know with your whole body with your
whole body yes and whole like how do you
get to that point like are are there
things that you're ever like insecure
about are there ever things where you're
like you know what like I actually don't
want to show that part today or like are
you just full blast confidence to be
able to perform like that on screen um
you have to just be able to
compartmentalize like if there's ever
anything that I'm like not feeling good
about like there's definitely been days
on set where I've hated the makeup
and it doesn't matter you just have to
like you just have to be like you know
what I'm hot the makeup's going to be
off in around 2 minutes anyway like just
get out there and suck that dick is the
makeup everywhere do they do your whole
body oh no it's just your face yeah tell
me about body makeup I mean look they'll
some I don't recommend body makeup
especially when you're doing porn
because you end up sweating it off and
then if you don't like I used to if I'd
have a bruise cuz I bruise easily I'd
try and like cover it with makeup but
then it actually draws more attention to
it cuz you could never fully cover it
and then yeah it's like what I did to
her yeah I just embrace it I'm just like
yep and I bet you everyone's like oo a
bruise she got nasty my mom always
played rocketball when I was a kid so I
always think thighs are supposed to have
bruises all over them just welts all
over them bruises are hot would I ever
put bruise on my leg I'm like I'm hot
it's like So Courtney Love of You Yes I
don't find them hot on me no I don't
care about it on anyone else when I have
a bruise on me I hate it I hate being
bruised BR really it's like been a
nuisance to you yeah I yeah I don't like
it at all do you ever ever someone do
something really light to and you're
like there goes my week thanks I feel
like after being in Pawn so long my my
body has adjusted like I don't bruise as
easily as I did when I first entered so
I think I'm I'm all right but yeah I do
like if a guy spanks me I'm going to end
up having like a a wealth and
potentially a bruise in the shape of his
head so hot but now that you're the the
Angela White like I'm sure you could be
like I don't like this makeup I don't
like the the way the light hits this are
you able now to kind of I mean now I
request certain makeup artists and I do
like even if I was working with a makeup
artist I didn't like certain things i'
give constructive criticism and say hey
can we you know bring the lashes up or
what whatever it is that I don't like so
I do make adjustments but some days you
just whatever you're just not feeling as
sexy as you would on on a normal day and
you just have to to get out of your head
and not think about that cuz my fans
have seen me in the worst makeup and
they still love those scenes so I'm like
okay they don't care I relate to that
more runny probably I relate to that so
much cuz it's so true like some days you
don't feel sexy and for that to be your
job you have to like you do have to like
work that muscle of figuring out how to
like conjure it up because even in
comedy it's like sometimes you're not in
a good mood but you literally have to go
out on stage and be fun MH and that
not that is like a whole different skill
set of doing it when you're not feeling
it and how do you go through like for me
you know if I'm different weeks of the
month I like when I'm ovulating I feel
insanely beautiful I love myself and
then a week after I'm like I'm an ogre I
can't even stand the way I look and you
just do you have those days or you just
power through and you're like I'm a
[__]
goddess well I will say that it's the
fact that I haven't Built My Career on
being the hot girl is actually helpful
because the reason fans lack my scenes I
mean some are here just for the tits but
they come for the the they come for the
tits but they stay for the emotion so
the thing that I'm known for is being
really connected with my on screen
partner so it doesn't matter I that's
check your panties hot that's that's hot
I should have worn black I just think
that should that's like everyone's thing
that is my thing too it's like yeah that
is so powerful and the fact that you
have the awareness to know that that's
your thing like that's really cool well
I'm not like um I'm not the prettiest
girl in porn it's like I'm there are
girls that are way hotter than me way
way better like you know I mean I know
it's all subjective but I can look and
go oh wow they have like better bodies
or they're cuter or whatever it might be
like I'm my fans love me because of the
way I connect
with the person on screen so even if I
don't think I look that great I'm like
well as long as I'm giving my all
authentic yeah then they're going to
love it would you say like like cuz what
is your advice for people like little
lowly people like us like if we did want
to try to feel sexy or fun or good on
those days where we're not feeling it
like what would you say to do like how
how do you do it I try and get out of my
head and into my body and by that I mean
like I'm not f focused on like what my
body looks like but I'm focused on what
my body's feeling so get out of your
head and into your body so I'm focusing
on what his or her fingertips feel like
as they run up my thighs I'm focused on
you're present yeah I'm present in the
moment that's where I go to and I mean
that's where I even if I'm feeling like
I look super hot in the end that's where
I'm going to because if you're focused
on bringing your on screen partner
pleasure or focused on you know your own
pleasure then you're not thinking about
how oh I don't like the color eyes
shadow that they used or I'm feeling
bloated or you're in the moment yeah I
feel like that's generally applies to
having sex and like with anyone like on
and or off screen right for me I know
that when I start thinking about
anything outside of just the pleasure
itself like I check out my [__] dry Stu
yeah you know what I mean yeah it's also
start worrying about things I'm like
call my
dad I'm always like oh I hate that when
I do to-do list sex oh my God [__]
and then it's hard to get back in it
really applies to acting too cuz it's
like if you're doing a scene and I'm
like I have no idea what I'm doing here
the the ultimate fix is like okay just
literally be in the moment and React to
what this person is doing and like
that's the trick of it yeah that's so
impressive now what if you're like let's
say you have a date or a
scene and physically it's like what are
you doing to prepare like do you take
like special showers or like eat a
certain way like how are you going to
optimize like your physical performance
depends on the type of scene if it's
just a regular girl girl scene or boy
girl scene then I'm waking up I'm
showering in the morning I'm making sure
like everything's clean um I mean you
kind of prepare for a regular scene as
if you're going on a date so you shower
you wash your hair you wash your face
you moisturize your whole body um yeah
you just kind of think about like how
you would want to present to someone if
you're going to potentially be having
sex with them later um then for uh the
regular scenes we douche so we don't use
the like the solution in the douche cuz
that's really bad for your vaginal
health so we pour out the liquid and
then replace it with just warm water so
we just clear out anything I mean I
don't recommend that we're like we're
listening
fix her legs she was like yes she's like
Diane Walter or what's her Barbara
Walter so you douche how douche for the
[__] enema for the butt so enema always
what kind of enema just the always new
she- shirts I don't Ana always like only
if it's an anal scene oh so only for
only for an anal scene and I know you
have a very specific diet like the night
before before anal scenes right yeah
what is it
um well depends so basically you don't I
I know my Transit time so I know how
long it's going to take for food to go
in and then come out so I I time it the
night before I don't eat any salads
because it doesn't really digest
properly and when you're cleaning out
it's like it's just you want to I mean I
usually either don't eat anything or
I'll have like a bone broth or something
just something very light and I time it
right so I know that by the time I'm
cleaning out I've had the correct number
of alas so everything everything's
that's actually why they call it bone
broth um Julian can you relate to this
oh yeah yeah wait really what's your
prep I mean usually like a high fiber
the day before um so that it you know
pushes everything through and then you
want to dou your enema before and yeah
now are we ever canceling dates because
things have not moved as fast as we want
them to no you just do different things
you know I mean the gay man's plight is
very different sexually because there's
different things you can do and you
don't need to do penetration and focus
on oral and you know just kind of work
around it but is there a lot of Grace
you offer somebody if it's a more
spontaneous meeting yeah and if it does
get a little bit messy you're like yeah
we're just yeah I mean like in everyday
situations like if if it gets messy it
gets messy like we're we're all gay men
and like we like my hey Mom my first
time I
farted and really yeah and it was fine
like it was like that's just kind of
normal sometimes you know I maybe it's a
butt queef yeah it's just a queef yeah a
butt queef yeah yeah um and then have
you ever had to like cancel like get
your period randomly and then you have
to cancel no people just work with the
sponge in oh really you don't cancel
yeah you don't cancel for okay
menstruation how does a sponge work you
just it's like every other job you can't
get one day off hurts I know I'm like if
even they don't cancel I know the [__] a
sponge so you douche a lot so that
you're like clearing out all the blood
and then you use a makeup sponge you wet
it first I like to put a little bit of
silicone lube on it because obviously
you don't want to stick it in dry cuz
that's painful and then you just stick
it up as far as you can and yeah the
guys don't really feel it they this is
literally the greatest advice I've ever
how do you get it out is it hard to get
out oh I would love to tell you how to
get it out because I still hear so many
horror stories on set where girls can't
get it out and they're always getting
the guys to try and like pull it out
with their long fingers but the easiest
way to get it out is to douche again
because what happens is you keep
douching and it fills up with the water
so it gets heavier so you douche douche
douche bear down and it it should just
come out with the water and if not like
you just keep douching keep filling it
with water bear down and it should come
straight out I thank you you're like a
scien you've just done such an important
this is like the most important thing
I've ever heard in my life well thank
you the when you were on tiger belly we
started talking after off camera um
about how to prep even for anal in
general and for someone like me where
it's always just been a very negative
experience where like I think the last
guy rated me like a six out of 10 on
from the anal experience and I was like
what happened he was like you just
looked terrified and you were like face
down and stiff and I was like oh yeah
yeah six six is actually a very well I
knew you were going to rate me I guess I
was a little you know one man six is
another man's 10 thank you maybe some
guy likes the stiff fear no
unfortunately I think a lot of anal guys
like that I think that's one of the the
terrified look no but you were um
explaining to me how to do um how to
massage the area first and how you can
eventually get to the point of
experiencing like real pleas pleasure
anally because I know for men I mean
your prostates there so it's much easier
but like I don't really have necessarily
anything in there that's going to make
get like oo this is worth it yeah um but
if you stiffen up you're going to like I
was telling you your [__] and your
jaw are connected so if you're clenching
your jaw you're clenching your [__]
we all have TMJ yeah you need to open
your jaw fire every doctor I've ever had
because you've just done more work than
they've ever done for me just come to me
I've played a doctor oh
perfect okay so if I'm tightening my jaw
or anything really but your jaw
especially like don't clench your jaw
when you're trying to get penetrated
because you're going to clench your
[__] relax your jaw deep breaths in
and out think like meditative breaths
relax your whole body and to be in that
state you really have to trust your
partner and you're going to have to
trust that they're going to go slow so I
don't recommend anal necessarily on a
one night stand I mean unless you're
already like Pro and you've already
practiced at home fingering yourself
using toys because you get that's what
you told me so to finger yourself so
I've been trying to use the anal plug
instead and working my way up the
different sizes
perfect thank you jul you get a gay man
class there's a thing I heard about
called spiritual disarming can you look
that up please what is that
it's what is going on I'm so glad this
is coming up okay spiritual
disarm disarming and if there aren't
butt plugs involved it's not the one I'm
looking for okay aren't you glad your
mom's here for this episode Stella I
mean honestly she loves it you're
learning a lot right mom um I just heard
about it it's like they put you put
vibrating dildos and and plugs in every
orice and for hours for they do Jade
ones you know people are using the
different crystals to but they have to
be vibrating ones or just any type of no
I think well I think my friend might
have sent it hold on and what is what
are the benefits
how I cured my existential crisis with
my butt plug I mean maybe it's like that
hold on let me find this is that what
you're Angela are you familiar with this
no I'm
not um hold on I'm G to find it but I I
think I like where this is going like if
you relax your butthole everything falls
into place I think it's like you just
it's like you just come for so long that
you no longer all of your in I don't I
think it's supposed to be not like on
purpose sexual but obviously it's sexual
just as a person who's present
constipated yeah in the present moment
that we're in talk about being in the
moment I would love a relaxed shamanic
dearmoring you're like I don't think um
constipation has anything to do with how
relaxed or tight your [__] is I had
so much diarrhea as a kid I think I
learned to just be in a full clench I'm
always keyling my assle shot I was like
I don't want to you're either a diarrhea
girl or a conation girl I'm a diarrhea
girl I had both but I got kicked out of
Nursery School okay I diarrhea so hard
because I had constipation so then they
were giving me all these laxatives I was
just lactose intolerant but when I was a
kid they didn't like really it wasn't
like popular so nobody really doose
intolerant kid that's so weird because
usually you become that I am a quarter
Jewish um it is a and there's some
things but um it uh so then they gave me
this La set of and I [__] I guess two
days in a row I diar on the carpet and
they were like if she comes in one more
time like I got like on academic
probation how do you put a kid on
probation how old were you well I was I
mean I made up that was that I was four
I was a baby St Paul's Nursery School
coming for you do you have been to also
have constipation
advice porn porn fixed all of my stomach
issues because you have to get so in
touch with your body to be able to
because it's not like a random hookup
where you can I mean obviously when
you're on a porn set things happen maybe
you have to cancel but for me like my
professionalism has been such a big part
of my brand that it's like if I'm booked
for an anal scene then you know you're
going to get an anal scene and I'm going
to be
clean cool is that but to get to that
that level like I've had to learn my
body like I've had to learn everything
like every like what any piece of food
does to my body how long it takes for me
to like for it to Transit like how it
makes me feel like the reactions that my
body are going to have like I've had to
learn everything so that I can know that
yes at 8:00 a.m. I'm going to be clean
and we can [__] all day and there's
going to be no I'm so inspired like you
are such a level of professionalism that
is so impressive like I think in any
industry people who are at the top
sometimes it's like it could go one of
two ways right it's like they're either
like slobs and like late and like hard
to count on and you know or like it's
like I'm right here they're not
slobs or it's like what you're saying
where you are just your reputation is
everything and you are on it like that
is so inspiring to me and also like
there would I feel like you're the
ultimate human if you're so in touch
with your body your every little
movement like I don't know I'm I want
that is and also this is a guess but is
is your um desire for professionalism
less about your reputation with everyone
else but more your reputation with
yourself like yeah it's me it it comes
from yeah I just I I love what I do and
I love being professional I'm also like
there's so many stigmas and myths and
like assumptions about people that work
in my industry like assumptions about us
being unprofessional or not having other
options all that yeah yeah yeah so for
me to like be an Exemplar of
professionalism is really important just
to I mean that's that's who I am at my
core anyway but it's just an added bonus
to be like okay well that's very rare
she was here before all of you so that's
professional she was she was the
earliest to get on set today I turned on
all right
um so I think we're going to get into
Truth or Dare y'all a classic sleepover
game are we excited can you read this at
some point too oh that's right it's
called shamanic
dearmoring and I it's not big enough for
me to read but Julian you can do it you
can't read it I can't I know can someone
read this I don't i' someone sent me an
article and I need to bring it here so
you guys will read it this is really
interesting sounds do they specify what
body parts need to be vibrated I think
it's all of them I it's everything yeah
it's not your butthole it's all the yeah
it's your butthole your it's like all
the holes how is that different from a
Thea
gun we miss you as our sponsor Theon we
do it's the holidays Oh yay sleep so
cute thank
you thank you I have this um reaction to
Dairy that I am in denial of because
I've been so proud of the fact that I
never been lactose intolerant but when I
eat dairy I get these cystic pimples
almost like overnight that's why you had
to cover the the chest one Annie my
third nipple that's a
stick that's tiny thank
you that's so good is it good I'm she
knows her
body I can't eat it
oh do not feel any
shame you guys I love my meundies so
much they're so soft and stretchy like I
was looking for something like this in
my life do you bring your like rollover
10year relationship like trash underwear
into your new relationships not anymore
not with our new supply of meundies I
won't thank you but I want to they have
this it's like a micro modal tensil
fabric whatever it
is softer than any other underwear I
have and I don't know why but they
really are so breathable um and I know
you guys sleep all AF fresa at night but
I would recommend um wearing meundies
you know when my parents are around I
cover up the cookie you know I try not
to Annie but they're breathable you guys
they're responsibly sourced and their
problem free philosophy is if you're not
happy with the first pair of undies it's
on me undies so to get 25% off your
first order plus free shipping go to
meundies.com
Tuesday that's me undies.com TR Tuesday
for 25% off plus free shipping that's
such a great deal especially for the
holidays me unies Comfort from the
outside in this show is sponsored by
better help for everyone who has thought
about therapy but is intimidated by the
thought I think betterhelp is a great
place to start I can't tell you how many
times before I knew of better help that
I was like all right I'm ready to go
seek therapy to seek help and none of
the people that were accepting my
insurance were taking new clients and
that's better is entirely online it's
designed to be convenient they have this
amazing Journal feature where I can
write down my thoughts in between my
sessions you don't have to worry about
parking oh and like one time I just was
in a really bad place and I didn't want
the video session you have the option to
just get on the phone and talk to
somebody and make it a phone call
instead of a video session and the
journal feature is also really useful
and great and you can switch therapists
anytime at no addition cost so you don't
have to delve into those people pleasing
issues to their face that's me find your
bright spot this season with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com TR Tuesday today to
get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com
Tuesday here's why I love price picks by
the way I just learned how how to do
this Esther it's made for you and me I
just say sorry to interrupt you but I
finally this has been so good for my
relationship because now that we're
messing with prize picks at home like I
actually pay attention to the games and
Dave like we have a common interest
exactly prize picks is the Tailor Swift
swift of businesses it's so fun it's
what brings people couples together I
think and here's why so you can
basically let's suppose Michael Jordan
was still playing for the Chicago Bulls
right and it's as 24 Point yeah he isn't
he I'm sorry to break it to you but yeah
he's fully retired you can basically
guess if he's going to score more or
less than 24 points and if you guess
correctly you get paid out how easy is
that it's as easy as as any of us in our
20s go to prize picks.com trash and use
code trash Tuesday for a first deposit
match up to $100 that's prize.com TR
Tuesday and use code trash Tuesday for a
first deposit match up to $100 prize
picks daily fantasy sports Made Easy I
love living proofs dry shampoo like it's
my favorite there's no other shampoo cuz
I will just be greasy and I and I won't
have noticed and I always need to have
one in my purse like I love living proof
it's always formulated without silicones
harsh sulfates SLS and
SLE parabens and phalates they're also
Peta certified cruelty-free color safe
and safe for chemically treated hair
over here I don't know what you're
talking about from now until the end of
November living proof is having their
biggest sale of the Year get 25% off all
orders over $50 which is a huge deal
huge deal and then also you get a free
dry shampoo if you spend more than 20
$75 but I will also say guys what I'm
going to do with this discount is just
stock up on these dry shampoos and just
get as much of a discount this is
actually insane if you spend more than
$100 you receive a free jumbo size dry
shampoo so if you go to their site stock
up on gifts from their sale get yourself
a free dry shampoo you're basically
making money take advantage of living
proof's biggest sale of the year now go
to livingproof
docomo and use the code trash tuesday2
at checkout to get in on these deals
before it's too late that's livingproof
docomo code trash
tuesday2 well thank you for the anal
tips I've been really taking heed have
you been doing more alone stuff I know
you said you've been graduating through
the the anal yeah and the guy that I'm
dating is very
understanding of the fact that I'm like
look if we're going to do this we're
going to do this right and you just have
to be patient and Angelus as this is a
process so yeah did he bring it up that
he wanted to do it um or did you bring
it up yeah Co yeah and I I've always
like jokingly said like once a year is
like the quota right but now I'm like
wait a second now I'm convinced it can
be
pleasurable and so I want to try it did
you try putting the toy in and then
putting a vibrator or Hitachi on it yeah
that one was really good advice that
worked really well I feel like that
opens you up more as well you put the
Hitachi on the end of the yeah I mean
you could put it on your [__] as well
but like if I ever have a butt plugin I
like to put the Hitachi on the handle so
it's vibrating inside or you could kind
of you know go from down there to you're
basically a
shaman you're basic what I'm getting at
is you a shaman only 13
sessions okay okay let's play so do are
my truth or daring myself um whoever
wants to start yeah just truth or dare
you can start I pick truth yep Esther
what is your best move in the bedroom
first of all everyone should have to
answer this okay okay great I think my
best maybe it's not a specific move
but and it's the advice I got in high
school when I pulled the PO popular girl
when I pulled the popular girl aside and
was like Hey can can you teach me how to
have sex and she was like sure and she
was like just do what feels good for you
and ever since then like that's been my
my Approach and I think that's a strong
asset I have
yeah your pleasure for sester great
answer Annie what's your finishing move
I don't know what's your Mortal Kombat
finishing move I mean I think I agree
with that like the best sex I have is
when I'm like using the guy's body as as
a toy basically thank you for being here
could have done it without you but thank
you for being here um I mean I don't
know I like you know I have my little
remote control I I Zip Zap I have a
hospital bed so I bring myself up to the
the height to the height of my fiance's
penis um I don't know I don't know my
moves I'll find out I'll tell you next
week I think my strength in the bedroom
is similar to yours and it's really like
being able to like connect cuz I think
that in my real life I sometimes have
problems with eye contact I'm a little
bit like like I have some stimulus like
aversions I'm not very good uh I get
nervous I get a sweat mustache any you
know that but during sex I'm really
locked in it's the only time where I
full abandon my inhibitions are gone and
I'm locked in so like my ability to like
connect and really kind of be sensual
and present but I'm really great on top
yeah hell yeah that's I think I've
gotten the most praise because I'm an
athlete I'm I cycle and I swim and my
cardio is on point and I will never stop
strength you got the core strength
whatever way you like me on top I will
go on forever so what's your best move I
mean it's definitely the connection but
if not the connection then um I mean
titty [__] is
definitely so jealous I need a jealous I
need a to do titty [__] yeah I can
completely make a [__] disappear between
my tips great yeah that's incredible do
you use like lube for that or Lube will
spit and usually spits easier because
I've just been sucking the dicks so is
there um how what is the proper way to
get titty [__] like and is there a
size like I mean is there hope for Annie
and is there a position that's
best um I think the best position is I
mean I do this in porn all the time
because it's really good for POV when
you think about it like most of the time
if a guy is lying down and you're going
over the top of him with your tits
that's actually really uncomfortable
because all of your weight is like
you're trying to hold your tits but then
you can't hold yourself up with your
arms like it just doesn't doesn't work
it doesn't look good it doesn't feel
good so what I like to do is I like to
have the guy put his legs over my legs
right so then he's Pro his butt is here
so he's propped up and his dick is
automatically in my tits and I can sit
up instead of leaning over like that
which hurts your back his dick is right
there and I'm just bouncing like this
and for POV and porn it's much better
because the camera is there right I can
look directly into the camera lens like
this I'm just bouncing my tits whereas
if I came over like kind of doggy style
which is what you do then my hair is
doing this I can't look directly down
the lens you're not getting the light in
there so whether it's on camera or off
camera it feels more comfortable for me
the guy can then thrust up the only
thing is some guys don't like the idea
of like their butt being cradled by your
thighs it's like come on it's more
comfortable for everyone and you get a
better view of the tip [__] and
surrender to your mommy issues okay you
all have them Just Surrender gets easier
Annie truth or dare I just realized you
had lion feet yeah my nieces gave me
these that's so cute it's right under
your left
foot those are only you think I know
left and right a they're still learning
me um those are only truths so truth oh
this is only truth
okay um if your current partner told you
he was transitioning how would you act I
would be like oh I'm so surprised oh
didn't see that coming you don't wake me
up with a Manina every morning he is
such a Tucker he also showed me the kend
doll where you just put it behind your
balls so it's just your balls
out I think boys are trans I like these
truth questions I'm going to keep it
coming Kila truth or dare you have your
I'm going to do truth they know how to
Pander to me this not a fun one but I'll
answer it Kila what was the hardest part
of going through such a public
breakup everything yeah yeah it's
humiliating it's I think the hardest
part though is people running with their
own narratives about you and um yeah I
mean that that can't feel good for
anybody like you know how it feels when
um even when you were younger and
someone spreads a rumor about you and
it's just like this and you can't fight
it because now 50 people believe it and
you're just one person saying but that's
not who I am like tenfold that's how it
feels like going through something that
public and like especially when you
break up with someone who's so beloved
and so charismatic and so funny and
you're sort of this like straighter
person then it's like I don't know it it
it [__] sucks everything about it
sucks I do not recommend and keep your
breakups private gals that's what I say
love you Kila love you K thank you thank
you do you feel like stronger though now
being on the other side of such a
traumatic event I don't I wouldn't
necessarily say stronger because I'm
still sensitive to everything I will say
that I am probably just able to hold the
pain a little bit better like the pain
is still there I just know how to hold
it and cope with it cuz that stuff
doesn't go away you deal with it on a
regular basis like you guys do like
we're girls in front of a camera I mean
that's an inevitable part of the sport
right it's like you're going to get a
certain level of like amount of vitrio
even though you get the good stuff too
um so just learning how to kind of make
friends with how painful it is I think
is the way to move forward like letting
go of like you're not you just can't
ever change people's mind you can't have
and it's just you can't there's no way
to control the Nar there's just no way
people are just going to say what they
want but that's like a good lesson too
and just self self love and being like
yeah I know the truth and there's just
no way to yeah you can't once a rumor is
out like you can't get it back like
there's no you cannot I have some real
nasty ones about me that are so
infuriating and they hurt are there are
there rumors out there about you Angela
where you're like [__] it just isn't
true about me I can't actually think of
any right now there's I mean there's not
so much rumors there's certainly
misconceptions about who I am as a
person because of what I do um there's
just there's a lot of like hate for
adult performers in general there's also
a lot of love so I focus on right
totally I focus on the love Do you feel
like it's getting better are you feeling
like a shift or is it still that same
kind of like crop of maybe certain types
of people that just really are just anti
what you do I just feel like everyone's
so loud on the internet right now like I
but I I feel I
feel um I don't feel so bad about it
knowing that there's also so many people
that are so loud in their support so
yeah I mean people are going to have
their assumptions I've kind of tried to
talk about those myths and destigmatize
the industry and and you did a really
good job you ran for office for that
specific reason right yeah I did what
you not know that Angela ran for office
in Australia in Australia yeah to take
away votes from a woman who was
basically anti-sex work was it yeah was
she super religious no she was actually
running for the grain p which is usually
a very Progressive Party usually they
have like sex worker positive policies
and for whatever reason she was kind of
on this um anti-sex work feminist
platform wanting to shut down the
brothels in Melbourne which were legal
and are still currently legal but she
wanted to shut them down claiming that
she really cared about the women
involved and was trying to save them
when we all know when you shut down
legal businesses it sends it underground
and so it makes it more dangerous for
the women involved so yeah my whole
platform was was just not to win it was
just to draw attention to that fact and
to draw votes away from her so in the
end she didn't win so I feel like it was
a success that's awesome good for you
yeah yeah a lot of
claps um Angela Truth or Dare okay I'm
nervous let's
see Angela what gives you the biggest
ick in a
coaster I will say like I'm always
looking for something that I love like
about a co-star I'm I'm very picky with
who I shoot with so right now I have
like a roster of girls and guys that I
just really like so it's a pleasure to
be on set but every now and again I'll
work with a new performer and when they
get on set I'm always looking for like
what do I like about them I'm always
trying to focus on that cuz even if I
you know whatever I find their
personality grating or something I'll
find something physically about them or
I I'll just focus on the positives but I
guess the thing I I really like
intelligence so if if they're if they're
not captivating in that way then I have
to it's not an ick but it's then I have
to try and be like okay like less
talking more like focusing on you
physically or trying to connect on like
a physical in a physical way if that
makes sense that's super relatable I
think that you can give me a 10 out of
10 specimen and I will not find him or
her attractive if they are just spewing
like dumb [__] yeah and I like I cannot
get there no matter
what I no intelligence is everything a
less attractive person can talk them
into being attractive and an attractive
person can definitely talk themselves
out of being attractive yeah you know I
was on um fun with dumb dumbfounded and
um he was saying it's actually a lot of
pressure to be very good-look cuz I
think about if you're a very
good-looking guy you start at the very
top like you can only go down from there
like there has to be some kind of I
don't know like if I was a super if I
was like Chris hemworth say for instance
I'd be really afraid to talk and sound
like a dumb Dum because you you're
already like this level of hot now it's
only downward for you I also think it's
interesting like I have friends who are
like I
guess um society would say pretty
unattractive and um and they seem to be
very jealous of like good-look men and
I'm like goodlooking men still have to
like upkeep really well too it's like a
good-looking guy can't just have like
scum between his teeth and like scum I
don't think so but I mean I guess like I
guess it's like so when I look at my
friend that that I'm thinking of it's
like I think he's like it's kind of this
he's jealous of of a of a laziness that
maybe can go
into being really attractive do you know
what I mean a lot of the uglier guys in
porn are better lovers too so a lot of
like the guys on my yes list are not
necessarily like objective like they're
not they're not like the most attractive
guys but they they're really attractive
to me because they're so good in the
bedroom yeah they're making up for
they're like yeah more men believe this
when we say this yeah like they always
say oh she's just trying to be like a
pck Me Girl by saying she's an Ugo
Chaser but it's like no it's not that I
chase uggos it's just that usually men
who have not been viewed as like
standardly attractive usually have
they've had to build a personality
they've had to be funny or they've had
to do this so I'm not your gifts baby
that's like if it's like a hot fat guy
you're like hone your gifts exactly your
gifts go to the gym H your gifts do you
think it's true this thing I've heard
where they say like a woman can grow
attracted to a man but a man cannot grow
attracted to a woman does that feel true
somehow that makes some sense to me um I
think a man can start to feel like oh
[__] I'm well taken care of and I should
stay in this but never like ooh I wake
up one morning like she's so hot to me
now cuz they have more of a spontaneous
arousal versus we have more of a
reactive arousal right Julian I think
that's why gay sorry I'm not
generalizing gay men you're not but I
think that's why a lot of gay men are
very shallow because I think that it's
always about looks it's
I just think it's always about
attraction I think it's a lot harder for
a man to like grow that attraction
towards like that just that sexual
attraction like I found myself in
situations where I've lost attraction
but I've really let like that person
I've like connected with so much but the
sexual attraction just like was lost
somewhere along the way and I couldn't
find it again oh this is extremely
disappointing I know I'm Sor because
like men get gradually hotter and hotter
to me the more I get to know them yeah
it's I I think personally and maybe I'm
a dick uh but it it's it's hard it's
tough and that's why a lot of you know
gay men open up their relationships and
try to seek it elsewhere
sometimes I hope that's not the case I
mean I definitely I grow more attracted
to a guy or a girl like whatever if like
once I get to know them and I see like
how good of a person they are so I hope
I'm holding out hope that that happens
for guys too do you date women yes both
yeah what is
dating well it was like yeah I believe
that we're all going to be dating women
at some point when we really I think um
once Todd
transitions seriously though if my
partner was like I'm transitioning I
would be I don't know what I would do oh
my God you guys so um I've always been
the girl on the show that like loves the
half gay boys I call them the half gay
boys cuz like if they're a little bit F
or they have like some type of like
inclination towards I don't know if
they're a little bit you know this
softer saching in front of me like I'm
okay with all of slyther the sther it's
very gen Z of you this is what the Gen
ZZ is like but I'm telling you the guy
I'm dating now could not be any more
manly like he is the epitome of just
like manliness and I love it but I'm
also like what's wrong with me like what
happened to my love for sashing boys
maybe he'll start sashing later on I
hope I think we get everything we want
you're right so if you want it it will
come I feel so old and stuck in my ways
because at my shows I always ask like
what are the types of guys that the
women are into and the gen's always say
like guys who look like Les lesbians yes
or like it's something like that and I
I'm like oh I'm old like I'm not with
the they all look like lesbians now
though they D they like have nail polish
and stuff so it's not like I do like
nail polish for some reason I think it's
I don't know why either I'm like okay
boys let's go paint them up paint them
up and like when they wear the pearls
I'm like okay okay so that's what I did
to the manly boy the manly man no for
Halloween I made him I he's like I don't
have a costume I was like I'll get you
one at Party City so I got him um like
this disco outfit and I was like well
you have to paint your nails so he was
like I'm not going to do that I was like
please God it's just if it's not going
to be right unless you paint your nails
so he painted his nails and I took maybe
80 pictures of just his handsome on cuz
I'm like I got to like I always tell to
I'm like you could paint I was like you
can paint your
nails it's so cute I think cuz I think
my kind of and on my iasa weekend I was
thinking this too like I think
masculinity for me is more about like
uh men who are being like are in service
to the Divine like who are like
protective but are also like very like
attuned to what women need and are there
to kind of like facilitate and just get
[__] done because women have to bear
such a
load for society and the family and I
like that so those yeah that's great
know what I mean um those who are
attracted to the what did you call them
half gay boys I've it's probably so
wrong to say that but yes love it them
presenting maybe would you ever be
interested in um pegging like reversing
the role the penetrating role um I think
I've only been interested in pegging
when they like absolutely are so opposed
to it opposed that's yeah like when
they're it's the same way that guys like
want that's the reason why they want to
[__] me in the butt cuz I'm just like no
thank you no thank you so it's so it's
exactly the same you want to [__] them
in the butt yeah like I don't think I'd
be into like a guy who was like please
Peg me please Peg me it's all I wanted
like swapsies I I'll do you you can do
me we both say no yeah I don't know but
I do we both don't get what we want and
also get what we want I do have a
girlfriend who really enjoys thrusting
and it really turns her on to have so
yeah I mean I would do if Todd was down
I would I would P him but he would I
would want him to like want it but he it
would yeah you would want him to want it
I guess well I wouldn't want him to be
like this is my thing that I've been
doing secretly before I was with you and
didn't tell you yet have you done any um
pegging scenes and yeah I've done a lot
I would love to do you like it I like it
it's a lot of work like I I feel for the
guys like it's a lot of work it really
is have you um what are your tips on
making men come via the prostate it's
pretty easy it's so right the prostate
makes it so easy have you I've been un
uccessful lot of like salad tossing like
even just fingers like you don't even
need to do is it fingers in and up well
I usually put them in doggy Okay so it's
like yeah cuz then it's easier like I
can wet it with my tongue and then I can
like yeah like doggies yeah from behind
I find that really easy and then and I
feel like it can be really intimate too
because once I get like once I get in
there and I find my spot I can kind of
like if I'm not like stroking the dick I
can come like over the top of them and
like whisper in their ear and that kind
of thing you know I I feel like it's
intimate I'm like sexually 14 I'm like
always want to laugh when you guys I'm
like I need to that's what I was saying
on my weekend too I was thinking I was
like I need to like get into my [__]
more because I am like we had a guy had
a foot fetish on like two weeks ago I
was crying laughing like I couldn't like
I was like hyperventilating when he was
talking about it like I like such a nerd
like when people say pianist I still
laugh like I just need to like grow up I
just need to grow up now if let's say
someone's watching this episode and
they're just like really curious like
where's the best place to see more of
what you're talking
about where would you first direct them
to go it's really easy Angela white.com
oh yeah and is that how we could get to
your only fans yeah it'll direct to my
only fans okay and is that probably like
the best place to start yeah I I
actually just released a new pegging
scene I mean other the scenes too but I
want a peg will you be our Peg mentors
sure okay I'm looking for mentors no I
need um I haven't successfully done the
prostate thing um I think not on it's
not no fault of my own it's more like a
an inability for the man to relax and
just say like just be like look Just Go
With It yeah um so I'm going to need
some tips there next time hi to Todd's
family I will be pegging your
son hi to my parents what up
this is another week what
up Mary what's up hi to the boy I'm
dating you will be back as well thank
you so much for teaching us all that
we've learned today it's my pleasure and
for making what I assume to be a very
exciting only fans that I'm sure
everyone's going to enjoy not Esther
though not me
but um so yeah Angela
white.com and I hope that you come back
and hang out with us again I would love
that and update us on if you learned
what dating is yeah I don't know if I'll
ever know yeah thank you so much this
was really I learned so much from you
you have a really good energy thank you
thank you we'll see you guys next week
[Music]
bye and